the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
welcome I'm really excited this is the
second year this class is a good student
I've been teaching it so hopefully a
little bit of the growing pains have
been worked out it should be a fun good
class so today we're gonna talk about a
bunch of different stuff it's all kind
of high-level and most of this class is
pretty low level detail and this is high
level to give you the macro view before
we dive into the more detailed stuff
it's the way I sort of think about it is
it's like a toolbox of stuff you'll need
every day in this class either in the
back of your mind or the front depending
so it's sort of just these random bits
and pieces and I apologize there's no
good way to make it be any more cohesive
than it is but hopefully it'll hang
together so we're going to talk about
energy in the world generally talk
review a units review a little bit of EE
do a little bit of estimation practice
which will do almost every time we meet
and then just talk about the class and
homework and stuff like that and I
forgot my dongle today so I'm sort of
working off of two computers I apologize
if that gets too crazy okay so if you
can grab the document that has a graph
on the top left corner we're gonna go
through what life is like using a bunch
of different development indicators we
got from the World Bank in different
countries and the countries I picked are
Nicaragua because that's the country
where this class travels to over spring
break
and I'll talk more about that later
Haiti because it's the poorest country
in the Western Hemisphere and so pretty
close and it's been in the news a lot
because of some of the tragedies they've
had United Arab Emirates because this
class is also taught at master art
student of Science and Technology there
and there's also a differently very
develop nation the u.s. because that's
where we are China because they're also
in the news a lot and then the dr congo
which the deciding who's the poorest
country in the world is a kind of
impossible task because it depends on
what you count what it is but dr congo
ranks as one of them
so you can see already there's some
pretty severe differences in these
different countries in terms of the
population the surface area and then the
resultant population density which you
can imagine is going to have a big
impact on the quality of life so I'll
leave it at that and then we'll draw
conclusions at the end so now we're
gonna do what I would call a ludicrous
quiz because it's going to be difficult
so the way you'd do this and we're going
to do together is first try to guess
what the biggest number should be on the
y-axis so what's the largest dni per
capita in US Dollars and throw out some
numbers gni is the average income a
person makes gross national income
so 30 K anyone want to stay higher 45
can we go higher lower okay and what do
you think the worst-case scenario is
what's the what are the poorest people
making 5 anyone more optimistic than 5
dollars per year okay and then best
guess on who's gonna be the one up here
this should be fast fun I won't judge
you if all right guess for us anyone
want to guess someone else okay and the
poorest Haiti okay so now know that one
all right
so in reality us yup you guys did great
with those five is a little low by an
order of magnitude or two and Haiti is
the poorest country in the Western
Hemisphere but not in the world that
would be Congo and so or one of them and
so yeah they're in fact the lowest all
right so now it's gonna get harder so
what percentage of people have improved
access to water this one we don't have
to worry about the y-axis because we're
talking about percentages so we know
we're at a hundred percent so let's take
who do you think has the best water
quality access and what percentage of
people have access to clean water in
that country the US and how much
99 so basically 100 anyone want to be a
different country or more pessimistic
okay a little less than 100 okay and
then who do you think has the poorest
the Congo okay so let's go check this
out
so the UAE actually beats the u.s. in
terms of clean water and we actually we
forgot to ask the percent I forgot to
ask the percentage so oops on that but I
think generally it's higher than people
guess however these numbers are always
complicated in terms of what does that
actually mean in desert does that just
having access to clean water mean a
hundred percent of the time are the
people collecting the data actually
getting good data or is there a bit of
cheating going on to make your country
look better than it is which happens a
lot so these aren't necessarily
confidence to be confident on one of the
things I find really interesting is that
China and a cargo are almost at the same
level and Nicaragua is a much much
poorer country a lot of other measures
than China okay
next improved sanitation so who do you
think is the best and at what level UAE
and how much 90 UAE anyone else this is
a class where it's great to participate
and you don't need to be shy about
guessing wrong because we're all
guessing here this is not a type of
thing you're gonna know off the top of
your head yeah improve sanitation so
unimproved sanitation is you poop in a
hole and maybe that hole goes down to
the river and pollutes your river maybe
it's behind your backyard and just sits
there maybe you don't even have a hole
maybe you have so this would be improved
to a level that you can the World Bank
considers it actually making a
difference in terms of people's health
if you go to the World Bank website it
explains it more succinctly and more
technically than I can
exactly so um again this is for urban
access not for rural access because in
rural areas you can have a deep hole and
that'll work fine if it's dug in the
right place whereas if you earn an urban
environment there's just too much
population density for that to work so
any other guesses for best case the US
and how much ninety-nine okay and then
what's what do you think the low bar is
eighty percent oh you said Haiti Hey
okay and I'm sorry and what um and this
these numbers are all from before the
earthquake
so it's worse now in Haiti and what
percentage do you think in Haiti 50 okay
50 30 20 some where in there okay so
Haiti does indeed win this one and this
was before the earthquake so it's worth
worse now as I said a lot of that has to
do with population density that Haiti is
just so dense that it's really hard to
manage there's more people in the urban
areas than there are in most other
countries and here the USA is a little
bit better than the u UAE in terms of
Sanitation um there's a sheet that'll
handout that has all of these so you can
write it down if you want but you don't
have to frantically record everything
I'm sorry I do not warn you that earlier
okay so energy use in kilograms of oil
per person so now you don't get the easy
hundred so these are getting harder
pension so how many kilograms of oil do
you think a person in the u.s. uses per
year
300 price is right high-low honey one
all right throw it a number a thousand
anyone want to go up an order magnitude
or down
so by that I mean going up to like
10,000 instead of a thousand or a
hundred thousand when it's this crazy
numbers where you don't really have a
good sense it's kind of meaningless to
say 300 or 400 at all this meeting with
meaningful is like 10 or 100 or a
thousand or a hundred thousand any other
you guys happy with this okay
UAE USA someone else China anyone else
okay so they could be using a lot too so
those are all possibilities
all right on the low end what do you
think the lowest number might be of
kilograms of oil I'm sorry
hundred Congo and how much 10 anyone
want to go to one or hundred okay
so there's a lot we use way off you know
by an order of magnitude we're at about
10,000 is where we are again these are a
few years old so China's catching up but
it's nowhere near where the US or the
UAE is yet
and then haiti and dr congo or you guys
were low by an arm attitude so even in
the poorest countries there's still a
decent bit of oil being used for a
variety of energy purposes so with oil
and all the other things comes emissions
so what do we think is the emissions
this is getting again even harder to
guess metric tons per capita of carbon
dioxide emissions so how many metric
tons do you think you are responsible
for each year assuming you're the
average American thousand ten thousand a
hundred thousand a million a billion a
trillion one hundred thousand
I'm sorry I heard a number that was
thousand all right
and you won't want to go above 100k okay
and then what about below that should be
relatively easy because it should scale
right so if you if we know that on the
previous graph 10,000 was that high
energy and a hundred was the low energy
then we should be to order two
magnitudes smaller right so let's see if
that works but that means we'll be
between 1k and 1,000 minus 2 zeroes is
10 yeah so who wants to guess where the
high and Lois where what countries
hi
hello
okay so Congo is indeed low it doesn't
even register and metric tons is a big
number so you guys are nice and high on
that we're talking about 10 rather than
a zillion and the UAE again is winning
over the USA and China is not
competitive was not competitive yet I
don't know that they are yet either
okay so electric power consumption let's
do this one fast so kilowatt hours do
you guys have any sense of what a
kilowatt hour is can anyone give a
physical example
so a kilowatt-hour so thinking about
light bulbs is a great approach so that
would so kilowatt-hour so yes so
definitely how much in an hour
do you know how many watts a typical
light bulb is 60 so it wouldn't be one
light bulb right it would be 60 times 10
to get to 600 to get times 2 basically
to get 2 kilowatt hours so that would be
20 lightbulbs in an hour so how many per
person or is it per person yeah
how many ordered into 20 you know how
many sets of 20 light bulbs are are we
powering each year per person
a thousand hundred thousand
and low
50 okay so I'm gonna stop worrying about
countries because it's getting a little
bit repetitive so in between you guys
were spot-on and here the USA does come
ahead of the UAE naturally because the
UAE is loaded with oil and we're not so
we do use more coal generally a little
bit of nuclear to fire our plants but
mostly coal and you can see that in this
case Haiti is very low down even
compared to the Congo in terms of how
much electricity they're using and you
can infer how much electricity there's
access to mobile cellular subscriptions
so this is no longer getting quite so
ridiculous in terms of numbers that we
can't imagine so how many on the high
end how many mobile prescriptions per
person do you think there are so per 100
people so 80
so this is the the population I assume
they go with like they don't go to
infants I assume they go to starting
with people who might have a cellphone
but I'd actually don't know that
question answer that's a good question
like 90 100 okay and who do you think
wins us-china anyone else wins okay
and then on the low-end how many
30 anyone want to go lower higher on the
low end ten five okay and who do you
think is on the low end Haiti who else
okay so this one's pretty interesting
and this is year-to-year so in 2008
there were more than two cell phone
subscriptions per person in the UAE so
they like their phones they're in the
u.s. we're not quite at a hundred yet so
but we're getting close to everyone
having a cell phone on average and there
is that some people have more than one
phone issue but you can see that in
every place there's a pretty strong
growth curve and that's why the cell
phone companies are raking in the Bucks
right now worldwide like Haiti going
from 1 to 34 that's a pretty phenomenal
growth and everyone even the Republic of
Congo is doing pretty well though
thinking they were at the top I'm afraid
it's not the case but certainly the
growth rate in developing countries is
really high because people are getting
cell phones before they get a lot of
other more developed devices and then
lastly Internet users so what's your
best guess they're 90
u.s. UAE I don't know I think this study
was probably done before that was quite
as prevalent because even like in 2008
you were using your phone for internet
access a whole lot yet less than you're
doing in 2011 but let's say I actually
don't know so I can't even sing but say
something but yeah I'm not grading you
on this so doesn't really matter it's
just to give a sense so what a 90 does
anyone want to take a different and then
on the low-end 21
okay so here you can see that we're
pretty far behind in terms of internet
versus cellphones which isn't all that
surprising so the u.s. is lower the UAE
is a whole lot lower and in the
developing countries like Republic of
Congo
you might remember I think they were at
14 people had cell phones per 100 and
they're at half a person per 100 so
internet access is a whole lot lower and
you can think about the reasons for that
and they probably make sense why it's
harder to get internet access than cell
phone access in a developing country so
that was a ridiculous quiz what might
you take away from those ridiculous
trying to guess those ridiculous things
you mean where do you learn classes
absolutely I'll support that my house
yeah
yeah in developed countries absolutely
do I don't think that will come as a
shocker to anyone who's read a newspaper
in the past five years but yeah but it's
helpful to see the actual numbers as
opposed to just a gut sense totally what
else
crazy
yeah so a technology that actually
really works for people is gonna be
embraced absolutely and one like an
internet workstation or you know may not
be one that is embraced because it's
impossible to embrace so that's a good
takeaway too one thing I take away from
this is that there's not much gut
instinct here for me either hmm that we
talked about you know metric tons of
carbon dioxide emissions we talked about
all these different things in the news
but do we actually as MIT scientists and
engineers who are some of the brightest
people in the world on these sorts of
topics know these details
heck no so when you're starting to think
about what it means to do this work in a
developing country making assumptions
like how many cell phone users there are
or how many Internet users there are or
any other detail about life is a pretty
dangerous thing to make an assumption on
and you have to get the data in order to
in order to do good work there are some
trends with poverty that we can take
away so you did see like Nicaragua the U
the Congo and Haiti we're always on the
lower end compared to the more developed
countries are looking at but Haiti
Nicaragua and Congo all took turns who
is the lowest and so even though from
you can very distinctly say who is
making the least per you know income per
capita that doesn't necessarily
translate to who has the fewest
cellphone subscribers or something like
that and the last thing is when you
watched yeah you have a question
yeah well it's gonna be
never develops
that sure would be and that's one of the
challenges for doing this type of work
is everyone pretty much wants
hypothetically to lead a life where
everyone has a car and everyone has air
conditioning running or heat running
24/7 like we do and if we try to create
our environment worldwide we're not
gonna have a world very long when others
that take away I have is that there you
can get an assumption if you've never
traveled to developing countries when
you see the photos of charity for
commercials and stuff like that of how
hard life is you can assume that life is
completely dire and that zero percent of
people have access to clean water
zero percent of excess electricity no
one has a cellphone and that's not true
either
and so you either want to assume that
everyone has this but you don't want to
assume that life is impossible and
everyone's living you know in sort of
the Dilbert mudd universe where all you
have is mud and that's it which is easy
to happen if you've never traveled and
all you see are like Save the Children
ads on TV not to bash a the children but
their ads are pretty stark this is tough
okay one other way to think about
development is just to look at the world
at night which NASA does by compiling a
bunch of photos and pictures at night
and so you can very quickly see where
lights are and where the wealth is the
drawback being that fire also creates
light and so areas where there are big
fires will also look like they're well
developed and so that's often the case
that in Africa there's fires burning out
of control and that's why it looks like
it's developed so but just like a
kitchen fire is not going to show up on
a NASA graph but it's an easy way to
sort of think about where our population
sensor centers in developed countries
and then also where is enough money to
have electricity to have lights so you
can see things like India is actually
free lit so it's and that plays out in
terms of how India is doing its really
been skyrocketing in terms of its
development and so there's a lot more
electricity there than there was though
there's certainly plenty of work to be
done in that country to make life easier
was that a question yeah
yeah yeah well it's kind of fascinating
I think in every developing country
there's not an even distribution of
wealth just like in this country you've
got you're Bill Gates and Warren
Buffett's and you have people who are
starving to death in this country you
have that true in every country in Haiti
you can see mansions and you can see
hovels and you can see that everywhere
and so there's always going to be that
uneven distribution where ever you go
so Nicaragua why did I pick Nicaragua as
the place to travel well it's a pretty
great place in terms of renewable energy
sources so you can see that it has a lot
of different sources it has wind on the
coast
there's a bunch of volcanoes would
provide geothermal energy that they're
taking advantage of rivers that can
provide hydropower solar energy because
it's basically on the equator and they
grow sugar cane so that you can grow
ethanol so it's this really nice place
in terms of lots of opportunity as
compared to some other countries where
there's fewer natural resources and so
if you want to start in a country it's
nice to start in one where you have
something to start with
but Nicaragua is the second poorest
country in the Western Hemisphere behind
Haiti and yes Haiti is well behind
Nicaragua and more so after the
earthquake but Nicaragua still has a lot
of need I forget exactly when but about
10 or 15 years ago Nicaragua was about
70 percent renewable energy and as
people's desire for energy has gone up
and the cost of oil has stabilized
they've actually sunk back down to about
30 percent renewable energy which is a
sad thing especially considering that
nikka Costa Rica I think is about 90 or
95 percent renewable energy so it can be
done Costa Rica is a next door neighbor
to Nicaragua but their goal is by 2013
which is getting every closer they want
to be at 3% oil which is pretty
ambitious given that they're at about
70% right now so there's also but that
translates to there's a lot of interest
in Nicaragua to use renewables
so that makes doing work in that country
easier as well
they're also close by because we're
traveling over spring break and that's a
very fast trip the idea of flying all
the way to Africa and spending half your
time in the air and spending all of your
budget on the airplane tickets is not a
great idea so that's the other reason
Nicaragua is of interest okay so let's
talk a little bit about energy so we
talked a little bit about how much
energy is used worldwide so let's talk
about where it's coming from and you can
see that coal and oil really dominate
where our energy is coming from and all
these renewable energies that we talked
about are pretty microscopic so the
world has a long way to go before we can
actually reduce our greenhouse gas
emissions and things like that there's a
really big problem with this slide does
anyone see it
email me if you find it give you extra
credit I say again it does that up okay
so and now exergy and for the purposes
of right now you can consider exergy and
energy to be basically the same thing in
your head that's a total lie and if you
know anything about extra do you know
I'm lying to you but it's not that
critical to think about the difference
and so you can see where are we spending
our energy and it's actually pretty well
distributed between all the different
needs not entirely other is carefully
constructed to be about the same size
but this what this means is we can't
just somehow magically replace all the
cars in the world and solve all our
energy problems or somehow magically
stop needing agriculture and have no
more greenhouse gas emission problems
there's a lot of issues worldwide that
need to be addressed and they all need
to be taken into account okay
so and why is it so hard to switch well
the energy density of what we're used to
using so diesel and gasoline and such
are awesome compared to a batteries fly
whales compressed air some of the things
that we talk about as being the great
alternatives and so going from something
that's an order of magnitude worse and
it's harder to come by it's not an easy
sell because it means is going to be a
whole lot more expensive and less
pleasant to use so that's why this is
such a difficult problem but because
we're running out of those really
awesome ones we're going to have to
figure it out
okay so units check-in so one of your
sheet says units check in on it and so
you can pair up I preferably with
someone you don't know and go through
the units again I'm not going to grade
you on this but I would like to have you
turn it in with your name so I know who
where the class stands overall on this
knowledge and you guys can work in teams
and just turn one sheet in
this is an area where only grab one
where hypothetically we should all know
every answer is MIT remember members of
the MIT community I know there's a
couple of people from Harvard so maybe
you get a pass but because you're not
necessarily an engineer or scientist
that I wasn't trying I wasn't trying to
slam Harvard but these are actually
things that there's a few in here that
are a little subtle like inductance that
you're not gonna need to know that was
just to check check how everyone's doing
but most of them torque work power
energy pressure resistance those you
should know are you out so that those
are things that are all really useful to
know for the rest of your life it's
really handy to know how energy and
power relate what is energy what is
power and something that most people
don't know including engineers and
scientists and is an embarrassment to
our educational system that most of us
don't so I hope that through this class
you will be forced to get it into your
brain for long enough that it'll stick
so yeah definitely learn that stuff all
right so why do you energy anyone
you've got your units in front of you
maybe that'll help
measure potential work so well then
what's the difference between work and
energy
so energy is the ability to do work
anyone else
the the measure of potential work did
you say
and then what
work them
I can't hear you back there time for
service
force over distance okay can you give me
something that's a little more intuitive
because I don't have a good a great
intuition of fortune for distance though
kind of I do I think I can work that out
yeah okay so the thing
that confuses me about that is you said
work is force over distance and then you
said it's the energy to moving objects
over a given distance so then I would
think the equation should be e over D
naught F over G
for us
okay so force over a distance okay cool
any other definitions
okay so the way that Saul Griffith likes
to think about it and I took these
slides from him he's an MIT alum who
does a lot of work in energy realms as
well as design and other great stuff is
it's thinking about lifting an apple
from the ground to a table so does
anyone know how much in apple weighs a
Newton yeah that's a really good guess
does anyone know how much in Newton is
so well well so a kilogram in a Newton
relate and how do they relate yeah so
we're just talking about mass versus
weight right so mass is disregarding
gravity and weight is regarding gravity
and so a Newton is taking into account
gravity but yeah an apple is about half
a pound which is about a Newton so I
have two apples here so you can get a
physical intuition for that because
physical so just pass them around
physical intuition is really really
handy and I know the lengths of my thumb
so that I know how long in inches and
how long seven inches is and hopefully
have some sense of weights and distances
too so that's why it's really nice to
have an equivalent and you can even take
that Apple and feel what it take what
physically feels like to lift that Apple
from the ground to a table and so
because a table is about a meter so
we're talking about about a Newton meter
which is your Joule so then what is
power
yeah exactly
so we could think about how many the
watts associated with moving a bunch of
apples from the ground to a table so
moving 40 apples from the ground to a
table is 40 watts which is the power
associated with a light bulb and so
light bulbs are using a good bit of work
if you think about how much work it
takes to move 40 apples from the table
to the from the ground to the table you
can do it but you wouldn't want to do it
all day every day for as long as your
lights are on right for a second yeah so
you're doing that every second you're
powering your light bulb hypothetically
so does that make sense to everyone if
this is a good analogy for you awesome
use it keep it in your head if it's a
terrible analogy for you which it
probably is for some of you get creative
and think about what might be a good
analogy for you you can Google on the
web there's lots of different people who
explain this in lots of different ways
but these are two concepts that is
really good to have in your mind the
other one that I like to do which is a
little obscure in some respects but
really helps me is to recall that power
is analogous to a velocity an energy is
analogous to a distance so that's
another way to think of it in addition
to the Apple analogy and however you're
thinking about it so running that Apple
left I never know what this HP IBM takes
but it takes about 60 watts so it's
moving 60 of those apples every second
for as long as I keep it on the other
way to think about in addition to apples
is lightbulbs because again we have
lightbulbs as a quantity that we kind of
know and we know that you know like
powering it
bulb is a whole lot easier than powering
a toaster oven or a space heater so you
can kind of think in those terms so when
someone says something is you know a
kilowatt generator you can think of what
we did before you can think about how
how many light bulbs in a kilowatt yeah
yeah so energy and power are the
difference is whether you're thinking
about time or not
so energy if you think about it in terms
of distance I can say that I walked a
mile today and you can say great and if
I did it in four minutes you can say Wow
and if I did it in four hours you can
say unimpressive and so energy is just
telling you that the equivalent of how
many miles you walked and power is
telling you how quickly you did it both
are really important so a light bulb
that's 40 watts is telling you how much
energy is going to be required in a
given amount of time to turn it on to
keep it on it's confusing I promise you
I will screw up and say the wrong word
occasionally and if you do when you
catch me I really appreciate it
so all right so let's do it oh sorry are
there any questions about all of us it's
hard to think about I've been in grad
classes where students screw it up
royally so don't be sad and if you do
but it is really important to get a good
intuition on it in any energy class and
hopefully as every engineer scientist
will have one by the end of their career
hair
any other questions
okay so hopefully this equation looks
familiar to everyone is there anyone who
doesn't I know this is awful to ask but
is there anyone who doesn't this doesn't
look familiar to because this deals with
something that it's an assignment that's
due tomorrow so if it doesn't look
familiar I need to give you a different
assignment because it's not fair if it
doesn't look familiar and you don't want
to embarrass yourself right now or not
embarrass yourself but be open about it
let me know after class so what's the V
what's voltage
I couldn't hear all that so voltage is
what is joules per Coulomb anything else
yeah the difference in potential I
apologize about my handwriting
and can you think of the analogy the
classic analogy for voltage he said
water pipe stuff yep
so what's voltage yeah so the water the
height the water the water pressure all
right how about I current yep and
current is amps and stuff the flow yeah
and that analogy is easy you can think
of it as the flow and then what's our
and so that would be the owns yep go
ahead
yeah so the pipe exit diameter
etc yeah so this is a handy equation to
know we don't have to do too much ee in
this class but you definitely have to do
electricity always bugged me because
it's invisible and as a mechanical
engineer I don't really enjoy thinking
about things that are invisible so I
think it's tough and yeah I like the
flow-rate analogy a lot thinking about
the pressure and the water flow and the
resistance to that flow that helps me a
lot so why am i reviewing this to you
what is useful about these quantities
so in this class one is we can predict
battery life so batteries are measured
in ant hours so how much flow over how
much time so you can know how long your
battery is gonna last which is really
important when your say sizing a solar
system a solar panel system or something
like that
secondly not destroying LEDs so I'm
about to give you an LED and a battery
and ask you to figure out what size
resistor you need to connect the two and
then do a couple other things so let's
review how to calculate that really
quickly can anyone walk me through it so
the battery is a 9-volt yep so the LED
is a twenty milliamp hour LED what else
you need to know
yeah so how long you're powering it
might be important in this case it's a
flashlight so it's let me you're going
to turn on and off and you can probably
estimate how long you're gonna need it
the voltage you're absolutely gonna need
so it's a three point six volt LED does
anyone know what LED stands for and does
anyone know what a diode is go ahead
yeah
yeah so it's absolutely a one-way gate
and the light emitted diodes happen to
emit light when the current passes
through which is really handy so the
one-way thing is really important to
remember when you're connecting
everything if it's not working that's a
hint you'll notice that I drew this led
with one leg longer than the other
that's because that's how they come and
that's a hint as to what direction you
should put them so you can do that by
trial and error but once you figure it
out then you can write down with the
longer leg which what direction that
needs to go in so we know that our
battery is a 9-volt battery awesome we
know that our LED requires 20 milliamp
hours and three point six volts and so
and we know we've got this equation and
you I told you that you need a resistor
so we're probably looking at what we
want the resistor to be so what do we go
what do we do from here yeah
to drop off that much maybe your sister
yeah exactly there any questions
okay cool so I'll explain the assignment
but that's going to be very useful all
right so that would be another reason
why you need to use that information is
if you don't use a resistor you're gonna
blow your LED and you only get one so
you don't want to blow it power is equal
to the voltage times the current that's
another useful one does this look like
any other equation you might have seen
in a mechanic's more oriented mechanics
what power is equal to how I squared R
so you said
yeah yeah yeah absolutely so and it does
indeed equal I square R so but in terms
of mechanical power and work are this is
it over the time yeah exactly so myself
I just froze but yeah so the so power is
what's another way of thinking about
power work overtime yep
and what's work
so again
yep so and what's a jewel
say again a new Newton meter
let's say again exactly over time so CP
yeah exactly so however you get to it
power is equal to force times velocity
and so which it's annoying because we
only have so many letters in the English
language to work with this velocity is
different from that voltage but you can
sort of think of the voltage as a force
like pressure and I like a current is
sort of like a velocity and so that's
how to get back to relating the
mechanical side of things to the
electronic electronic side of things and
something they never told me until I got
to grad school there's all these
equations you use in electrical
engineering and all the equations you
use mechanical engineering are all based
on the same formulas when you go back
far enough in the physics and so they're
all just talking about the same stuff
we're just using different assumptions
and different variables so if you're
more comfortable in the mechanical world
figure out what it is in electrical
engineering and do the translation for
your in your mind or vice versa
it's a nice trick if you these are
totally unfamiliar concepts these are
two books that I posted on stellar that
I would recommend grabbing out of the
library to be a refresher starting with
the shirt's book so a lot of this class
we're gonna do estimation because it's a
really handy tool for doing work in
developing countries and as engineers
and everywhere so we're gonna start with
how to estimate the energy in that
9-volt battery that I'm about to give
you that we just talked about so here's
the 9-volt battery and how do we energy
estimate the energy is ordinate
yeah how long to power something like a
flashlight so let's go down that path
so what do we need to think about in
order to figure out so the reason I was
put that underscore there it's just
because you could think about how long
it takes to power something else if you
know that better than a flashlight but
yeah this is a really good way to think
about that so what do we need to think
about in order to know that so how long
does a 9-volt battery power your
flashlight for
yeah so how can we get a rough number
for that
okay but it's still a light bulb yeah so
a small light bulb so it's we are
powering a little light bulb so what do
you think that light bulb might be rated
at hmm 20 watts anyone else have a
different thought ten
all right so generally in estimation you
go with orders of magnitude that we're
talking about before so if you know
specifically that you're using a 20 watt
light bulb put that 2 in but if you
don't just go with 10 or 1 or a hundred
and then hopefully you're the small
digit will cancel each other out but in
estimations we're never trying at this
level we're never trying to get to an
actual exact number that you're going to
use in a specific equation that you're
gonna use to actually like design a
flashlight you're just trying to get an
order magnitude can I power a flashlight
or can i power this light bulb with a
9-volt battery or do I need a bigger
battery type of thing so let's go with
10 watts so we know the flashlight or
the the lightbulb is 10 we think the
flash of the light bulb is 10 watts
what's next someone else no you're doing
great yeah okay yeah yeah so let's
multiply it by time and then what will
we have yeah we'll have our energy
awesome so how long does your flashlight
last
ten hours so what happens if I do this
what's wrong
yeah my units been totally off so ten
hours
so what units do I want yeah so 60
minutes per hour times 60 seconds per
minute is 3,600 times 10 times 10 so
what are my units now joules yeah
awesome so does that sound good so 36
kilojoules I when I did this I the way I
did it is I've never had a flashlight
that uses a 9-volt battery I only have
flashlights that run on D cells or
double-a cells or whatever so I didn't
really have a good sense of how long my
light bulb would last on ten hours and
so I estimated that well first I thought
about how a battery works and how does a
battery work and really simple 15 years
or ten year old terms yeah so there's a
chemical reaction which requires
chemicals which are volume based right
like you could you you can sort of
change the layering of the different
plates that you need in a battery but
fundamentally you can only have so many
chemicals in a battery so I thought
about it like two doublea's is about the
same volume and said it's equivalent and
then the therefore I said all right well
my my um my flashlights I forget how
long I thought they lasted I thought my
bat my bulb was actually five watts so I
cheated and put a 5 in there instead of
a 10 or a 1 and I thought it lasted just
an hour so I got
this many duels which I believe is
actually closer to how long a nine-volt
will last depending on how good your 9
volt is so you can see but we're still
like you guys are still in the same
order of magnitude so we're golden it
doesn't really matter but just to give
you a slightly different approach so now
let's try talk about estimation so why
am i bugging you to do this in an energy
class so one is that it's really handy
when you're in a meeting say with a
community partner and a community
partner says I want to you to install me
a solar panel and my roof is this big
and I want it to power all the ovens for
my kitchen you might be able to very
quickly rather rather than saying I
don't know or that sounds stupid you
might be able to very quickly do the
equations to say actually you need a
solar panel the size of a football field
to make that work so let's think of a
different method it's a really good way
to gut-check your work or your other's
work so other people's work so if you've
read in a newspaper that someone's come
up with a new magic energy source that
does this amazing stuff you can really
quickly check and see does this make any
sense as the reporter not doing due
diligence or when you come up with an
answer on a homework set or design
problem find it out and then also saving
time and money
that you don't have to spend the time to
figure out that so you know respect that
whole solar system that that community
partner ant wanted before you've
actually figured out is the solar panel
gonna work at all for you
estimation tends to feel really hard and
that's really legitimate so there's a
lot of reasons that that's the case one
is that you're used to problem sets
where there's generally a right answer
and exams where there's generally right
answer certainly that was true in high
school and often is true even at MIT and
an estimation there's kind of a right
answer but there's a lot of different
assumptions you can make that could give
you a lot of different right answers
you're also used to defined realms where
you know you're going to be given a test
and it's going to test you on these ten
equations and how to use them in these
five realms and that's all you need to
know
and this is out of that comfort zone and
totally in a different space you
typically have no resources beyond your
brain so yes we have Google you can
always use that but in this class we're
often going to be doing it with no
Google and so all you have is your brain
and so it's nice to be able to lean on a
textbook or Google or whatever it's
often in public so there's little time
there's a little warning that can be
terrifying
you'll see me screw up you may screw up
it's hard but it's really worthwhile as
I talked to before again it's open-ended
it's ill-defined there's multiple
acceptable methods and answers the
significant uncertainty is a light bulb
actually five watts or ten watts or one
watt or bigger it's hard to know exactly
if you can't actually look at the light
bulb and that can be stressful and then
you have to have the set of knowledge
that you don't just know values or
quantities or relationships but you know
all of them in relation to each other
and that is a lot of knowledge so that's
one of the reasons that I'm trying to
push you to have these units at your
fingertips as well as having some
quantities like how much is an Apple
things like that so that you're gonna be
better at estimation because part of it
is practice and practice is huge we're
going to be doing that a ton and the
only way to get decent at it is to
practice but part of it is having those
quantities in your head already so that
some of that uncertainty disappears so
what are the actions that you can take
to do effective estimation so
identifying a problem system so that
generally involves drawing these
pictures so I drew my battery and I know
it needs to power a light bulb and I
know they're connected and that is a
good way just to think about it drawing
your system always seems to help in
problem-solving identifying a quantity
within a system so in this case we
identified that there's a battery and
it's nine volts and we identified a 10
watt or five watt light bulb providing a
value for the quantity so I kind of
skipped combine those two right but you
could think all right I need to know the
voltage for this I need to know the
wattage for that and then think about
what it is
and then also with time we really did
that we thought about time then we
figured out what it needed to be
counting a set of things so I'm trying
to think of a good example for counting
a set of things so for example like if
you're estimating how many seats there
are and 10 to 50 you could count a row
and then multiply right so or if you're
estimating how much how many light bulbs
in a kilowatt you count one and then you
multiply comparing two systems for a
quantity so I compared my doublea's to a
9-volt because I'm more comfortable
thinking in double a's than I am in nine
volts every time you do that you know
you're making another assumption it's a
little risky but it's better than doing
nothing by far identifying a
relationship between quantities so we
did that power times rate is the energy
and then we have changing a system scope
so that's what I did getting from nine
volts to doublea's and identifying a
similar system oh I guess scope could
also be or system or system could be
thinking about this chemically like you
could skip all these energy equations
and if you were a chemist and really
comfortable chemistry you could just
figure out the chemical reaction and do
it that way I'm not a chemist so that's
not the way I'm gonna pick but it would
be another approach and then as I
mentioned practice okay so now we're
gonna do a harder estimation together
and then we're gonna take a break
because I know three hours is an
incredibly long time to sit on
uncomfortable chairs in a poorly laid
out classroom so how do you want to
approach this bicycle problem
I'm sorry oh yeah so this is estimate
the drag force on a bicycle and writer
traveling at 20 miles per hour and I
gave you a little help that's 9 meters
per second
so what do you think is bigger you think
the ground is bigger does anyone have a
different approach so I think the wind
is going to dominate and so you could
include the the wheel friction but in an
estimation you want to just look your
biggest quantity so I'm gonna say we can
neglect that friction and just focus the
drag associated with that body going
against the wind and this is the
question last year this is just a silly
looking bicycle that's why I posted it
because it find it amazing but we don't
need to worry about you know whether the
person is facing the wind this way or
this way we can assume the body you can
neglect that thinking about that so what
what do we need to think about
yeah so we can think about the service
area so how do you want to model our
person alright so a triangle we can do a
triangle we could do a rectangle the
equation for area of a rectangle is a
little bit easier than a triangle
because you don't have to divide by two
so let's go with rectangle because it's
kind of meaningless so what's the area
of average person half a meter squared
okay great so we have our surface area
here's anyone know how surface area
relates to drag force
so the drag force is equal to a drag
coefficient change the area
say again and philosophy
does anyone know that drag coefficient
this might be the best approach alright
so those are step one didn't work or
it's one that we could go after but
you're trying to answer this question
right now in the classroom without
looking up that drag coefficient and we
don't have any people who've been
spending too much time on fluid
mechanics so we're going to have to go a
different approach which is great so
what would be a different approach
so we have kilograms per meter cubed so
you're saying to multiply it by area to
get kilograms from one I'm sorry
mm-hmm so I think we're actually here
still so now we're getting an equation
that actually has the right units so
that's great
but because we've got it in the density
and we could say that this is just a
constant and we're doing an estimation
and so we can neglect it so absolutely
this would be one way so let's work it
out so does anyone know the density
there is basically one yep so and then
we have our area is 1/2 and velocity is
9 so that's basically five five what
forces in yeah so five Newton's so how
can you gut check if five Newton sounds
like a good number
okay so what is a Newton an apple all
right so we're talking about the weight
of five apples when you ride on a bike
at 20 miles an hour is that fast or slow
on a bike it's pretty decent yeah so how
many people have written a bike before
all right awesome so this is we're
getting into familiar territory great so
when you're riding on a bike does it
feel like it could be five Newton's on
your body five apples okay so if I said
it could it be 500 apples would you
that's ridiculous
if I said like zero apples you'd
probably say no you're feeling something
against your body so maybe we're in the
right realm cool great so good job
a lot of people give up on this approach
because you can't remember that that
constant or whatever or you missing a
term in this one because we need that
row in there but this one works the way
I do it the way I approached it is I
thought about the power associated with
bike riding so when I bike at the Z
Center it tells me the actually how much
work I'm doing how much power I'm
generating and so I'm kind of a terrible
biker you can tell them a little out of
shape
so but I know that I can bike some
somewhere on the order of 200 watts and
so that means I'm all set right because
now I have that and now I just need my 9
meters per second and what am I doing
wrong that's what I'm doing wrong I need
to divide and so then I get about 20
Newtons is that right they do that math
right sorry board fatigue what
thank you yeah I'm I know I'm not
actually dividing 9 I'm dividing 10
because there's estimation it doesn't
matter so we're kind of in the same
order magnitude we're a little different
but this is a nice approach because it's
just two quantities and all you really
have to think about is one and you can
this this 200 watts is actually
ambitious for biking for a long period
that's that's a lot of power you're
outputting so because as you can see it
you actually see it on the screen and
some people who are really into biking
know like Lance on what aren't Lance
Armstrong can do and what a normal
person can do yeah but so there's that
so this is just a nice way to see
there's two different approaches to this
problem and I'm sure there's others that
you could go after too so there's always
another way estimate how high a d-cell
can lift you and if you have a
background that's not engineering based
if you can find someone who is that
might be good to have the mix rather
than to non engineers working together
on this that you guys may do fine too so
it's worth a shot so yeah so take ten
minutes to work on that problem
okay does every team have a guess
does any team not have a guest or can
you raise your hand if you have a guess
okay great so did anyone have a
thousandth of a meter or hundredths of
the meter tenth a meter 10 meters so
maybe 16 100 meters for a thousand
10,000
okay so we're pretty constrained how do
these numbers strike you as reasonable
ridiculous okay but there's there's an
aspect to this that's ridiculous period
the question is a little funny right we
can talk about that so can someone go
through how they got 10 or 10 yeah so
basically what we did was we we did the
same thing that you did earlier we
thought about how long a t-cell could
power 10 watt bulb your DSL system right
how long it was due time to last for a
10 watt bulb right okay and we came up
with we came up with a number that when
we solved we've got 15,000 joules as the
energy mm-hmm
and and then basically like meat we can
be equated it with the potential energy
of a person weighing roughly 50
kilograms at a height X yeah so that
would be MGH that would be 50 into 10
into X mm-hmm and that would be equated
to 15,000 yeah and then you've solved
for X you know
and X turns out to be 30 okay did anyone
take a different approach I kind of led
you guys down to this approach given the
previous exercises so I'm not shocked
that no one did for the people who got
closer to a hundred what was the
assumption that was different that led
you to 100 rather than ordering 210 180
thousand joules and where did that
number come from so you guessed 10 watts
times 5 hours got you there so it just
it was really just because I think you
guys said 10 watts too so it's just how
long does it last 15,000 joules is about
what the nine volt lasted for and how
does the volume of a d-cell compared to
a nine volt so I would I would say a
d-cell is actually maybe 50% bigger so I
think 180,000 might be impressive but
but 15,000 is a little low but we're all
pretty close to the same ballpark so and
I actually think that the we're closer
to 100 than 10 depending on the
assumptions you make so but everyone did
great with these results so why isn't
there an awesome person list lifter
powered by a d-cell out there so we can
all get to the top of our roof to shovel
them off or whatever you need to do you
probably probably not shoveling your
dorm rooms but I sure need to shovel my
roof if I could get up there efficiently
yep
well necessarily like we I didn't you
say how much time it took
so yeah so there are some efficiency
issues but this exercise had actually
run in a classical to double a nine
which is the senior mechanical
engineering design class and a guy
called Nate ball came up I'm clicking on
the wrong computer with what he calls
the Atlas powered rope ascender that
basically does this of course there are
some efficiency losses so it's not
actually a d-cell it's a much better
battery but it's in the kind of the same
ballpark and so it's kind of amazing
because you wouldn't think that a d-cell
would have a chance of lifting you
anything right but the embodied energy
and a d-cell is actually pretty good and
at the same time I'm telling you that I
also showed you that graph where I told
you a battery is lousy compared to
gasoline so it's good in some respects
but it's also lousy if you actually
wanted to stay power an automobile with
a d-cell versus a person lifting up a
little bit automobile requires a whole
lot more energy to work okay so finally
after all this other stuff we can talk
about the class now now you have a sense
of what the class is gonna be like so
I'm Amy band's art I have a
three-year-old his name is Eli I do work
in developing countries mostly on
charcoal which is here about later our
ta is I meet Gandhi where are you there
I went to Brazil Guatemala and Brazil
before we have a bunch of other staff
who are helping Dennis Nagel works
downstairs he's the shop manager for
d-lab Steve band's art who you may
notice the last name is disturbingly
similar is in fact my husband and he's
also really good at double e stuff so we
help teams last year and he'll do that
again
Ken McCain E is a mechanical engineering
grad student Sarah Reed just finished
her master's here and Mickey was really
good in design work and then Amelia
servi also a mechanical engineer because
in the design class were kind of slanted
toward mechanical engineering support
and then we'll probably add a few other
mentors along the way so our syllabus so
if you guys want to break out your
syllabus you now know who's gonna help
everyone you can read the aims and the
objectives which I have worked pretty
hard to make sure that everything we're
doing aligns with those aims and
objectives so that should give you a
good sense of what you can hope to come
out of the class with and if those don't
align with what your hopes are for the
class maybe this isn't the right class
for you and if they do awesome I'm glad
to have you so this is a twelve unit
class which means hypothetically you're
spending six hours a week in class and
six hours a week out of class working on
all the pivot ease associated with the
class and I last year was a nine unit
class and Stevens said it was very much
nine units and they said there was not
nearly enough time to do everything they
wanted to do in the class which is why
we bumped it up to twelve units so I
think it is reasonable to expect you'll
be spending six hours a week out of
class and this is a class where
attendance is expected so it's I know
there's a lot of classes at MIT where
you can skip the lectures in the labs
and or at least the lectures and do okay
in this class
like those estimation exercises you
can't really capture what we did in the
lecture notes and so you'll miss the
learning entirely if you don't show up
so there are there is sort of a strong
punishment in terms of grades if you
don't show up to class without a really
good reason why not in terms of grades
being reduced for those reasons there
are two quizzes that happen in the
beginning half of the term just on the
material covered in the class the labs
and the left and the assignments as well
as assignments p-sets
lab stuff everything should be turned on
in via stellar unless it's something
that can't physically be turned in
electronically last year I had issues
with stuff getting lost and so this is
my hope that nothing will get lost so
just make sure it makes it on stellar
and hopefully stellar won't disappoint
are there any grad students okay so if
you want g-level credit as opposed to
undergrad credit you need to sign up for
a different subject number so just you
can talk to me afterwards and just send
me an email telling me that you're
signing up for the grad class because if
I don't know that I will not be able to
tell the person who gives who actually
writes in your grade the right grade and
then you'll get an F without me even
knowing that and that would stink yeah
the most of the readings are gonna be
handed out online basically so while
there is a required test text which i
think is a great text of paul Pollux out
of poverty it's totally something that
you could borrow from a friend or grab
from the library because it's not like
we're referring to it every week and you
need to have it heavily highlighted and
in your grasp at all times like you
would a math textbook or something but
Paul's a good guy so if you can afford
the book which is like 14 bucks it's
worth supporting him so the structure of
the class is the first half of the class
is kind of his lecture and lab heavy
it's sort of like a normal class where
like today we'll be doing talking
probably not as much talking as I've
done today ever again we try to do as a
lot of hands-on exercises in class too
but there will be a decent bit of
talking and then the labs which are very
hands-on and run by a meet where we
build a bio digester we build a solar
panel out of solar cells we build a
little tiny
wind-turbine you make charcoal you do
all stuff that's very hands-on relevant
to what we might be doing in Nicaragua
and then subsequently over spring break
most people travel to Nicaragua with the
class which is a really fabulous
experience that's extra curricular it's
not a requirement of the class to go to
Nicaragua but it does add a lot to your
experience actually working with real
people rather than than just being
hypothetical is a pretty valuable
addition and then after the trip you
come back and it's very much a design
class where you're working on a project
identified in Nicaragua or really
identified beforehand that you learned
more about in Nicaragua and then you
work on it for the last half of the
class the lab and lectures basically
disappear and it's all just work time
with a little bit of lecture content to
help you with the design process so that
part is pretty intensive and then you do
final presentations we hand off the
projects to Nicaragua one way or another
and the class is over so that's how its
split up what else one thing to know is
for people who are going to Nicaragua
it's really helpful to speak a bit of
Spanish and so one of the more random
homework assignments is to at least
listen to a couple podcasts per week of
a Spanish podcast like Spanish learning
podcast so you can at least say hi and
thank you and things like that if you
happen to speak Spanish already bonus
but if you and you know if you're fluent
no need to practice but if you're not
it's nice to to get a little practice if
you've taken like Spanish 2 or something
in high school it's nice to practice a
little because that stuff tends to come
back quickly if you practice and not if
you don't and I will start speaking a
little bit of Spanglish I have taken all
of Spanish one at MIT so I am NOT your
Spanish expert but I have spent by now
over the course of different weeks
probably a couple of months in Nicaragua
so my Spanish is a bit better when I
talk about technical things that I know
about in Spanish than just general
conversation but yeah so I'm not
expecting you to be a Spanish expert
through a technical class because that
would be ludicrous and I'm not myself
but it is helpful to know a little bit
of a language
finally just one thing is one of the
things you picked up is a muddy card
which you may or may not have
encountered at MIT and it's just a way
to give feedback to me about what you
understood what you valued about the
class what you didn't understand hated
completely anonymously and it allows me
to improve my teaching in the class I am
finishing up my PhD I have aspired to be
a professor so I really want to improve
and appreciate your help in that and
appreciate constructive criticism I just
have to be that constructive it's useful
for me and it's anonymous so you can be
blunt or if there's something you loved
it's great to hear that too just to know
what to keep in the class but I really
appreciate your taking the time to do
that and then we also have similar stuff
with the readings just get getting
feedback online on the forums do you
guys have any questions about the
syllabus and what I just went over okay
cool
so in order to get into the class
because it is a class where you get to
travel to Nicaragua there's a big
commitment in terms of we're working
with real people in Nicaragua and so we
want to make sure that you're here to
really work and not just to fill out
your class requirements or whatever we
do have kind of a strict what you have
to do so one is a student profile where
you just tell me about yourself
that's online link to on stellar and the
other thing is a DIY Lantern so I'm
going to give you all an LED and a
9-volt battery you can pick up a
resistor and you need to figure out what
resistor you need from the Edgerton
Center and this is all online - but it's
room for 409 this is the combo the
resistors are on your right so you need
to figure out what your sister is I
would recommend checking that the
resistor you pull out of the drawer is
actually the right resistor by looking
up the resistor code and doing the work
because the edge of the center is a
student lab and so resistors tend to get
mixed up and if you pick a wildly wrong
resistor you will
blow your LED or your device won't work
at all but on the flip side resistor the
the V equals IR equation in terms of how
flexible and LED is is relatively
flexible so if you can't find the exact
resistor you've calculated the value for
go up or down 10 or 15% and you'll be
fine so anyway so you're trying to build
a lantern out of found materials that
resistor the 9-volt battery and the LED
and what I care about is does it
function so does it turn on is it
possible there turn it on and off and
can I figure out that switch in a
reasonable amount of time
aesthetics does it look decent did you
use materials creatively so if you found
a lantern at EMS or REI tonight and
bought it and just swapped out the
internals with this that would not be a
very creative use of found materials so
I'm hoping that you actually find stuff
that's recycled rather and then
maximizing light is it actually useful
as a lantern so those are the criteria
and you can bring the lantern back to
just the room down the hall is is a 34
to 11 and just place it on a desk with a
piece of paper that has your name a
really quick sketch of the lantern so
that we remember what it is when we give
the lanterns back to you and just a
really fast explanation of how you size
the resistor so we know that you
understand that aspect of what we just
went over there any questions about this
assignment file materials
yeah so yeah
mhm
that would be one way to do it yeah
so I'm sure you can find some materials
downstairs you can that downstairs
there's a there's a non alleged in lab
the agent lab you can just get resistors
downstairs and we actually intentionally
tried to make this class a little short
so there's time to help you start this
project so downstairs in there's the the
d-lab shop and there's some scrap
materials in there that you can scrounge
or the recycling bins in dorms at least
back when I was a student here undergrad
student we're pretty full of wild things
that might be useful and MIT trash cans
are amazing woods they're just walking
the halls where people have piles of
stuff that they're throwing out there's
all sorts of stuff that you can grab but
yeah the idea is to just use found
materials because when you're in the
field you're often just looking around
in the trash heaps and yes the trash
heaps in developing countries and some
some regions are really more useful than
in other places and then here for
getting trash people are also more me
creative so they tend to use up all
their trash so there's not much left so
it's a trade-off so in some respects we
have worse trash piles and another
respect to be a better trash piles but
the idea is to make a lantern with with
trash and the components that I give you
do you have any other questions about it
yeah like components like a switch or do
we just be creative so
you have a a tradeoff a design trade-off
here I want it to function which might
push you toward using a switch and I
want you to be creative
which might push you toward using
something that isn't a traditional
switch and that's really your call and
so if you decide that the switch is the
right call because you're going to value
functionality maybe you do something
else that's I creative use of materials
in a different realm so that you try to
meet all things but in every design
process there's going to be direct
conflicts and I need it to be super
lightweight and I need to have a huge
battery pack that's a classic design
conflict and I'm trying to produce that
here no a resistor and so I will I will
hand you out an LED and a a 9-volt
battery right now actually I mean if you
want to do that and then you can get the
resistor from the edginess Center and
everything else is found materials so
the homework for this week is this
reading which is on line rate of
reaction piece the instructions for how
to write a reaction piece which it's
like a paragraph that's not onerous is
on the seller forum and then there's a
problem set with two problems on it
that's also on stellar yeah right so I
will let you know if you're in the class
by midnight tomorrow so that gives you
plenty of time to do the homework after
you find out so but conveniently fewer
people showed up then said they're going
to show up so the ratio of people
getting in should be pretty good so yeah
so if you guys can take five minutes to
do the muddy cards I would really
appreciate it and then you can leave you
can head downstairs and look for found
materials you can talk to me right now
whatever you want
you